when you made the decision to leave
saturday night live
uh you did six years on there yeah and
uh and in a great six years it was yeah
but that's got to be frightening as hell
uh i would think you know what howard it
was funny because when i was on the peak
of snl like when i was the most famous
like people coming up to me like adam i
remember warning me he's like soon you
know when i first started he goes soon
people will know your name and they'll
call out molly so that was happening
after mary katherine everything was
going great
i would get recognized it was great they
knew my work but that's when i got the
most depressed i went into such a
depression why because i was like
i would have this like anxious feeling
when people came up to me like oh thank
you thank you but then i was like a
gnawing anxious sad feeling like no no
something she said you were afraid of
disappointing people from week to week
that maybe you couldn't keep it all
going or said that your mother it was
sad because i really the the only one i
really wanted to tell me that i was good
was my mom and i'm finally i'm doing
backflips i'm now
doing this i do everything and she's
still not coming back you know and i
realized i was driven to achieve and
work and run and i'm just kind of driven
and driven and driven and drew doing my
stage show and like i said and then i
get the show
and i was like oh
the fame doesn't fix any of this i still
have a [ __ ] hole in my heart and i'm
so i got dead depressed for months and i
could finally feel fully sad about my
mom
and cry and cry and cry and and it gave
me uh it was freeing howard because
because i realized fame doesn't fix
anything it doesn't bring my mother back
from the dead i just thought that that
would kind of fix that hole you know
what i mean like right and it didn't it
didn't and so it gave me this like
freedom where i was like okay who cares
you don't have to be the best you can
just be whatever level you're at you're
doing what you love you get to be an
artist you're creative you're passionate
you're pursuing what you want who cares
if you're not number one like you could
be number you know 2000 just enjoy being
creative it doesn't matter so then i
really enjoyed that show like it was
like a creative camp and i'm like you're
working with it was like the best comedy
school imaginable so did you ever try
medication
i never did no i just let myself grieve
it i was in therapy and talked about it
so it just gave me this kind of like
really enjoying the show and because i
and you know people used to say oh you
got snl it's a great stepping stone i
was like a stepping stone
yeah i don't understand that a stepping
stone i was like this is the greatest
job i'll ever have in my life and i
still feel that way so why leave why
leave after six years because i loved it
so much i loved lorne so much i
respected the show so much i wanted to
leave when i loved it i've seen some
people stand too long where they're
phoning it in and i was like i gotta
hand the torch over and i really wanted
to spend time with my dad and i wanted
to date
i i was i had met fritz at the time so i
really wanted to spend time with him and
i want to just meet friends for coffee i
just wanted to have a personal life i've
been working so hard i was like i want
to just enjoy my life and just have fun
you